Who counted Anna out? Who is Who is doubting Anna? I'm checking
the chat. Who is doubting Anna? Stay in your lane. I didn't interrupt
you and and stay out of my >> up. Can you please respect
Israel? >> Oh, it's jihadist propaganda to be concerned
about dead American soldiers who were forced to fight on behalf
of Israel. My point is you YOU SEEM VERY
>> WHY DID PIERS SAY THAT THEN IF HE KNEW THAT? OR IS HE
getting Is he some Have somebody in his ear? Or
>> Okay, where were we going to? I think we wanted to do
this. Well, I'm joined now by my panel, uh which is includes
Ana Kasparian, executive producer and host of The Young Turks.
I'm just I'm just You guys can't see it, but I'm saluting, okay?
I'm saluting. Thank God. Thank God for Ana Kasparian. Thank God
for Ana Kasparian.
Thank God.
Uh Glenn Greenwald, the host of System Update. Jonathan Conricus,
retired lieutenant colonel. And Ideas Space
>> The fact that Conricus is on here, as soon as I saw
it was Anna and Conricus, I WAS LIKE OH, YES, PIERS. THANK YOU,
PIERS. Thank you, Piers. I get everything I want in the whole
world. Ana Kasparian on a panel with John Conricus. How you can't
even It's awesome. It's awesome.
I love to see you. >> Folksman, a former general and US
assistant secretary of state. And Goldie Ghamari, the former
Canadian lawmaker and Iranian
Okay, I just got to say this person is Canadian. They were a
part of the Ontario Parliament. Also, whatever filters they're
using are warping the [__] out of their face, okay?
This is absolutely nuts. Whatever is going on here. Okay, it's
it's better when it's frozen. As soon as it's in motion again
>> Welcome to all of you. Well, uh the Botox is probably
preventing it from being in that much motion, okay?
All right.
>> This Goldie Ghamari person
I noticed something immediately, okay? She's got some Iranian
stuff here. I think there's a Persian symbol of some kind, some
Persian stuff here with I think Iran there. Then she's got the
the lion flag, the monarchist flag,
She is obviously pro-monarchist.
Yes?
Then I noticed something else.
That for some reason she's got So, this person was a Canadian
She's got one very very very tiny symbol of Canada here. Then
a big American flag and then a big Wait, what is that flag? Hold
on, what is that flag? Can we Can we zoom out? We go to THE FULL
VIEW? OH,
I SEE.
I see.
I I see, okay. Now, we'll go through the report later. The The
network analysis is showing that a lot of these monarchist types
are actually propagandists, which by the way I sensed immediately.
I sensed this immediately,
okay? I had a I had a couple posts, a very misogynous posts about
some of these women. Okay, some of these Persian women who are
clearly like monarchists, total monarchists, and that
they're like clearly astroturfed, and I'm like there's needs
to be a total shutdown on these people's social media. I If you're
a Persian woman
between like 18 and 25, 18 and and 31 we'll say, okay? Your Your
social media has to be shut down until we can figure out what
the hell is going on, okay?
Okay, that was a weird comment. No, that's not what it is. It's
like um
Oh, is this Zoroastrianism? Okay, interesting. But I'm saying
that like we need a shutdown here cuz I see them all like waving
flags and [__] Like why are you shaking your and
waving this Persian this old Persian flag? Oh, it's cuz you have
like 4 million impressions on this. You have like 10 million
impressions on this. Huh. And I saw this before I saw the report,
okay? I immediately was like this seems really weird. And then
I saw the report, the network analysis from 2022, and I'm like
oh. Thank you. Connected a lot of dots. Made a whole lot of things
Made a whole bunch of things make sense there. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. >> lawmaker and Iranian
I don't even know how to do the hierarchy of my problems with
this person. Probably number one is you're a former Canadian
lawmaker with no nothing indicating this in your background.
Except this one tiny little leaf over
I appreciate if you loved your country. activist. Well, welcome
to all of you. Uh Ana Kasparian, your response to Mike Pence
there laying out a moral and legal justification
for these attacks on Iran.
First, I would like to ask Goldie whether she apologizes for
laughing as Cenk Uygur on the last episode he was on was talking
about dead American soldiers as a result of wars that the US
gets dragged into on behalf of Israel. Goldie, do you apologize
for laughing at the thought of dead American soldiers?
And I know it's Dude, it's so good, man. It's so good. >> Find
your jihadist propaganda lies. Everyone knows that Ella and I
were >> jihadist propaganda to be >> me when I speak.
about dead American soldiers who were forced to fight on behalf
of Israel. Interesting. Okay. Uh to answer your question here
>> the question? >> 175
little girls
Dude, just immediately out of the gate foot on the gas
instantly.
She's literally Persian Syrian girl. I do get that impression,
yes. Yes. >> slaughtered in an Iranian
Okay, hang on. Hang on. Okay, hang on. Hang on. Piers, man. Hang
on one second. Anna Anna Anna Anna, hang on one second. You asked
her a question, so I will let Goldie respond. Then you can respond
to my question. >> Well, she responded by claiming I'm
I'm sharing jihadist propaganda. I'm talking about dead American
soldiers. So, do you apologize or not?
May I respond, please? >> Goldie, quick response.
Thank you. So, we were laughing at Cenk's bizarre anti-Semitic
tropes about how Israel is responsible for every single incident
that happens in the war. We were not laughing at American soldiers,
and you actually edited the video. You edited the video, so there
you go. Everyone knows that you're lying. You're You're a laughing
stock. You're a joke. >> Everyone can go back and watch
What is this artifacting going on? Do you guys see this? You
guys see this? Like the the shadows don't cast correctly. Like
the the filtering is so bizarre. The shadows like don't cast
There's this lighting coming from the episode, the full episode
What is happening now? It's like so bizarre. It's so uncanny.
>> Okay. The only ones who were respecting General Wesley
Clark were myself and >> Okay, you know what? Look, you
Anna's you said your piece about Goldie, she's responded. Let's
get back to the bigger picture, which I'm sure the other panelists
would prefer us to do. Your response to Mike Pence both on the
moral argument because I do think that that there are lots of
people I know, including many on the left who can understand
a moral argument for getting rid of what has been a ruthless,
vile regime that has caused terror not just to its own people,
but to the wider
But all but hesitate about whether this is the legal thing to
do. So, I don't think it's just people on the right saying go
go go. People on the left saying well, I'm glad he's gone. I'm
glad the Ayatollah's gone. I'm glad a lot of the the top leadership
have gone, but I'm not sure this is legal and the precedent being
set is very dangerous. My view of this current war against Iran
is that Iran did not pose a threat to the United States. Their
ballistic missiles did not have the capability to reach the United
States. And the notion that this Confirmed, by the way, confirmed
by everybody involved. Confirmed by literally every person involved,
okay? Yes, they had no capacity to reach the United States. They
had no capacity to harm the United States. There was no imminent
attack coming towards the United States, okay? So, there is no
If you want to dispute Anna on this dispute some facts.
This was all about Iran's weapons was a lie from the very beginning.
This is about a regime change war on behalf of Israel. Israel
would like to be the hegemon in the Middle East. And the United
States is spilling blood and
using its treasure to help Israel build an empire that I guarantee
you will turn around and um well, we'll suffer the consequences
of that at some point. But we're suffering the consequences of
it right now. I mean, the first thing is Israel did is strike
an Iranian girls' school killing 175 people. That's according
to the New York Times, which typically likes to bury the wrongdoings
of the Israeli government and military. I don't see this as a
just war. I don't think that
President Donald Trump has a plan for what happens following
the slaughter of the Ayatollah or
Totally proven out by the congress people who went to the briefing
today, okay? Anna was correct. Anna is just going to stack Ws.
We now have future sight. We can see that Anna is now proven
correct on every point she's making. Except possibly I still
There might be some contention still on whether it was a US munition
or an Israeli munition that struck the school. It was definitely
their side. It just we're not totally sure on that. Anyway, we
continue. uh the destruction of the Iranian regime. In fact,
he has said as much. He said it is not the US's job to figure
out who leads Iran next, which means that there will be a power
vacuum. And we know how that plays out in other countries where
we've done similar things. And in regards to Syria, let's Let's
not mis Why is this guy shaking his head?
Why is he shaking his head? Hey, make a point. Make a point.
>> state what actually happened in Syria. Okay, the Obama
administration began arming Al-Qaeda terrorists. Al-Qaeda terrorists
who actually fought our soldiers in Iraq. And now we have a supposedly
former Al-Qaeda terrorist as the leader of Syria. We didn't do
good things in the Middle East, including in Syria. So, Mike
Pence No idea No idea. I know the US armed people in Syria. I
know they definitely armed the Kurds. They definitely helped
the Kurds there. I don't know if they I don't know what happened
in Syria in terms of US arming
I don't It doesn't really sound like something I'd
I It doesn't sound like something I'd disbelieve on its face,
but you know, it is what it is. >> joke in what he said
during that
Okay, Jonathan Cormack, just first off, the attack on the school
or the explosion of the school that caused so many deaths, particularly
>> The attack on the school. Sorry, let me correct. The
explosion on the school. of young We got to make sure we don't
assign any intent to that. It'd be very bad if we assigned intent
to that.
But let's also talk about the at this time three American servicemen
or men who were brutally murdered. It's like Okay, well, it seems
like we know how to assign Okay, I I just like pointing these
things out now because they all stick out like sore thumbs, unfortunately.
>> students. There does seem to be at the moment ongoing
confusion about exactly what has happened there. The school was
next to one of the Revolutionary Guard
bases. It would used to be part of
But it would have been a little further away than right next
to. It was like probably a couple hundred meters away. >> until
recently, apparently several years ago, it was sort of separated
from the base. And, you know, depending on which report you see,
but none of them appear to be definitive. This was either an
Israeli stroke American missile that that caused this to happen,
or it could have been an interception by the Revolutionary Guard,
or it could have been indeed a missile as some have claimed fired
by the Revolutionary Guard that hit the school
by mistake. We don't seem to know for sure yet. Do you Hold on.
I just that hit the school
by mistake. We don't seem to know for sure yet. Do you have any
intelligence that can 100% verify what's happened
No, I've been asked in various um fringe networks and I've done
a lot of interviews over the last 2 days and 2 and 1/2 days.
And, you know, that topic comes up when someone is grasping to
try to undermine
the American is and Israeli operation against the regime because
it is a relatively convenient tool to use. Usually, it's not
by people who have compassion for civilians, for Iranian school
girls, or for Iranians in general, but it's usually for people
who have I love being lectured by the IDF spokesperson on compassion
for civilians, okay? That's awesome. I love that. Thank you.
>> operation against the regime because it is a relatively
convenient tool to use. Usually, it's not by people who have
compassion for civilians, for Iranian school girls, or for Iranians
in general, but it's usually for people who have something either
against President Trump and his policies or very often against
the state of Israel. So, I've looked into it and so far
kind of a messy situation where I can't really make sense of
what happened, whether it's Israel or the US who's He's just
thankful to Piers that Piers did all the sweeping for him. He
doesn't even have to do his job. He just gets to show up and
do it get it collect a check today. Oh, Piers, are we Are we
double paying? I thought I was I thought I was going to be sweeping
today. Piers going to do it for me. Let's go. struck, or whether
it's some type of a false flag operation by the IRGC.
I wouldn't be surprised in any of the options. It could be an
American or an Israeli
Wouldn't you be shocked if Israel struck a school? Oh, no. Okay,
well. >> proper military target that happened to be too
close or collocated within or next to a school, and it could
be something that was cooked up by the IRGC specific specifically
for the purposes of having something to clutch at and having
something to feed international media to show allegedly wrongdoing.
I put that into stark contrast with, you know, very deliberate
actions of the Iranian regime when they are firing at seven or
eight sovereign countries in the region, and they're firing at
almost exclusively civilian targets. They're firing at cities
in Israel. They're firing, of course, cities and we already we
have I have 11 civilian casualties confirmed. All of them civilian,
none of them military. Most of them women and children, one elderly
man. They've been killed in various incidents where Iranian missiles
have exploded in Israeli cities. We have confirmed deaths in
the UAE, in Saudi Arabia, in Kuwait, and a lot of incoming missiles
on Cyprus, Jordan,
and and other locations. And, of course, we could speak about
this incident, and I'm sure that many people who have issues
with Israel would want this to be the story. They would want
one errant attack or one unexplained situation to be the headline
because it is what they It supports the agenda. These are by
I like I obviously know that Iran is wrong for doing all of these
things. I think that the total lack of planning on the American
side indicates that you guys didn't do everything you could to
spare these people pain. You didn't do everything you could to
make sure you had attack an attack plan. And by the way, the
United States infamous for this. The United States maybe the
best to ever do it, to hit enemies so hard and so fast that nobody
can [__] stop them, right? That no they can The enemies
can barely fire back at them. But it seems like they didn't get
that
Seems like some [__] went down where the US didn't
get a chance to clear all of their people out of the region.
So, that's probably what we're actually concerned about here,
okay? With regards to Yeah, I know the IRGC shouldn't be firing
missiles at US embassies or US bases in other countries, and
that's
But I'm very concerned with the actions of the of America's allies,
okay? Forcing them into this. And forcing those attacks out when
they knew they would be coming. >> By the way, the same
people who when Iranians were marching in the streets and being
gunned down by the Iranian regime, we didn't hear a lot of them
speak about what was going on, and we didn't hear a How is it
bad?
Okay, so I think it's bad because So, how should I put this?
They were targets before the US had been involved, and the US
knew that Israel attacking would make them targets.
Right? You could say
it depends on what's being targeted, too. The attacks on military
bases after the US had struck, not bad. The attacks on civilian
installations, bad. The attacks on Yeah, that's pretty easy.
A lot of those people who now allegedly care about Iranian school
Yeah, both sides bad there. speak about the atrocities of the
regime, and it is the typical hypocritical position of so many
people. It only depends on who has allegedly done the killing.
Doesn't
No, both sides are bad.
But they're like the Both sides are about
Both sides are bad in their military actions so far in this war.
Is the difference between the actions So, here's the problem,
right? I calibrate how bad I feel about it or how much it upsets
me based on the morality you you put out to the rest of the world.
What you tell other people you are. You The Iranian regime are
like evil, okay? They They've declared themselves like, "Hey,
we We're religiously crusading against all of the decadent West,
okay?" I expect that behavior from them. But then I have to swallow
the pill of like, "Oh, Israel's the most moral army." And it
doesn't translate. That's Maybe that That discrepancy is what
upsets me, okay? who was killed, America, too. America, too.
and how this can be cynically and politically used.
Okay, Jonathan Cormack, as we speak country that seems to have
an affinity for slaughtering children, and that country is Israel.
But anyway, No, that's actually Iran. The Iran now. That's actually
the country that seems to Is that true? Right. Right. Okay, we
also we also know we also in the poly market has bets on when
a nuclear strike is going to happen. I've got a lot of bets.
>> think from what's happened in Gaza, it is prudent to
get to actual facts before we pass too censorious judgment, and
I prefer to do that because I think if we don't, that way madness
lies. Um as we're talking, uh General Kimmit, President Trump
has told the New York Post that he's not ruling out sending US
ground troops into Iran if they were necessary. He said Operation
Epic Fury was way ahead of schedule by taking out dozens of Tehran's
top officials. He said, quote, "I don't have the yips with respect
to boots on the ground. There were Like every president says
there will be no boots on the ground. I don't say that. I say
probably don't need them, or if they were necessary." He also
told CNN uh earlier today that the big wave in the conflict is
yet to materialize,
indicating the US has not yet begun to strike Iran forcefully,
and suggesting more significant action is imminent. So, where
do you feel we are with this, General Kimmit? And how precarious
would it be for the US to commit boots on the ground? You know,
I talked earlier to to Vice President Pence about the parallels
here with Iraq back in 2002-3,
uh where committing boots on the ground turned out really >> Uh
I actually I don't even know what the capacity is to like within
the This might actually be the thing that I say this all the
time. Never mind. No, it won't be. I I I keep wanting to say
this should be the thing that like ends Trump, but it
It just won't be. They'll like turn the cults. It's somehow
I don't know how. >> could we be sleepwalking our way into
another disaster here? Yeah. Well, first of all, I hope there's
a little civility while I'm answering the questions.
First of all, as one of those boots that walked on that ground
in Iraq in 2003, I think that nobody wants to see us repeat the
mistakes
of that operation. >> wearing a fur. >> that matter,
as we look forward to whatever emerges
from
this situation in terms of the government, I certainly hope we
don't count on the expatriates to come in and solve the problem
for us. But look, I think it's important to understand we didn't
do regime change. It's highly unlikely we're going to do regime
change. We've done a But the president Can these guys just get
on the same page?
Regime change, no regime change. Boots on the ground, no boots
on Just get on the same page, man.
Come on.
By the way, has Trump decided which one it is yet? I actually
don't know. Hassan has said, in so many words, is we are doing
a leadership decapitation
as Israel did with Hezbollah.
And he said to the Iranian people, I'm opening the door for you.
You've got to figure out what to do after that. So, where we
are in the operation now, we've hit about 10,000 targets. We've
got a lot of work to do. But at the end of the day, we I think
this whole thing is trying to make it so the Iranian people do
go out in whatever numbers they can muster
and get slaughtered in front of the world. I think that's probably
the goal is to get as many Iranians killed as possible so that
you get a further impetus for the war, right? That's that's the
goal. That's what all these people are working towards. This
person, this person. They're working towards getting as many
Iranians killed as possible.
Right? They're going to convince them that they have support,
that this can work, that this will happen. They're going to go
out. They're going to get mowed down
by a totally not dislodged even remotely regime. And then we'll
go People will go, "Look, look, they're crazy. They're crazy.
They just killed a couple of
Well, no, they they don't want atrocities.
They want atrocities.
the guy who got elected, by the way, perfect guy.
The perfect guy. The guy. The guy. If you want that, if you want
atrocities, they picked the guy for it. >> We we can't
get mission creep in this operation. Seen it, been there, done
it. We ought to stick to our end state that we are seeking, which
is no nukes,
no uh uh ballistic missile program of any size, and no proxies,
because that was our end state at the negotiating table, and
the negotiations failed. We shouldn't be changing our
Wait, did the negotiations fail because
refused any of those things, or were they wanting concessions
for some of those things? I guess the negotiations were completely
capitulate to not being a country, right? Not having your own
armed force at all.
phew. object Talking that a country wouldn't accept that. Actually,
disarm yourself entirely.
Disarm yourself entirely or
and and be a functioning country. How? >> It's just because
we're using military force. The purpose of this military force
is to get back to the negotiating
and finally get what
three Why has Trump talked about trying to do a revolution there,
then? Why has Trump arming militias?
presidents,
ever since we've discovered the nuclear program, has tried to
get.
the fact remains is it's highly unlikely that we're going to
see that anytime soon, and the only way we're going to get the
Iranians back to the negotiating table for those purposes
is through strong use of force. And look, you ask, "Why now?"
And the very simple answer is, and legally, a preemptive strike
meets our conditions.
Do you want to be facing, across from that negotiating table,
a nuclear-armed
Iran with long-range ballistic missiles? Better to do this now.
You destroyed their nuclear capacity, their ability to create
a nuclear weapon, completely
less than a year ago?
Are you telling me that all of these years they've been building
up their nuclear program, and now, in a year, they got back to
where they were the previous year? Or what are we talking about
here? And just before I go to to Glenn Greenwald, when I spoke
to Vice President Pence, we talked about the parallels with Iraq,
and he was quite scathing
about Prime Minister Starmer's reluctance to get involved at
the first stage of this
refusing to allow Americans to use the bases, the UK bases, and
so on. What is your view of that? Because it it it did seem a
marked departure
in the normal practice of the UK to allow
forces to do that. Did you think that was a mistake by the UK
Prime Minister?
Well, I just appears you and I have been around a long time.
We went through Iraq together. The fact is, I think that Starmer
just did not want to be referred, as Tony was, as the British
poodle. So, I think what he wanted to do is give it a little
bit of time, make it look like this is an independent decision
of his, and rather than being We do have a special relationship,
but we're not tied at the hips, and Britain is not a proxy for
the United States.
We knew, particularly if the Iranians started firing back, that
Britain would come in the way that the Saudis and the Emirates
have come in. And and one last comment, um
on it Please quit using the tropes on American soldiers. I've
had to bury seven American soldiers.
The tropes on Americans? What tropes on American soldiers?
Bro, this guy
That's a Hasan [__] move right there, okay? As they
like to say. You to use dead bodies as your shield right now?
What the
They went into the battlefield. >> How was it a trope?
How was it a trope of Israel's wars? How was that a trope?
Explain that to me.
Nobody is dying on behalf of Israel.
I'm not going to dignify that with a >> you Let me let
me read you what Israeli media has been saying. So, American
soldiers came under friendly fire in Kuwait. I don't know if
any of them have died. Hopefully, none of them have died. But
on Channel 12, Niv Raskin said this. We need to emphasize this
is an incident involving American forces, and not, heaven forbid,
an incident involving Israeli forces. And why is he representative
of anything, Anna? Who Who Who makes him representative of anything?
Why are you cherry-picking >> figure in Israeli media.
No, he's not a huge figure. He's He's a talking head of the Israeli
government. >> soldiers is totally okay, I guess. >> Well,
okay. No, I want to bring you I want to bring you I would like
Oh, Anna just needs to say, "So, you totally disavow this commentary."
Conricus would Conricus is extremely well media trained. He would
He knows how to deal with this stuff. He would absolutely go,
"No, no, we obviously value American soldiers' lives. They're
like our heroes. We love America. America's a lion. America's
a mighty lion. We're just a little We're just a little badger.
America's a mighty lion."
No, no, no, it's not it's not Anna 4v1. Glenn Greenwald's totally
on Anna's side. I don't know why Glenn hasn't talked yet, but
Glenn's totally on Anna's side in like all of this stuff.
Okay, I got to pull it back 30 seconds. I just got to go I'll
be right back. 2 >> Kuwait. I don't know if any of them
have died. Hopefully, none of them have died. But on Channel
12, Niv Raskin said this. We need to emphasize this is an incident
involving American forces, and not, heaven forbid, an incident
involving Israeli forces. And why is he representative of anything,
Anna? Who Who Who makes him representative of anything? Why are
you >> This is a huge figure in Israeli media. No, he's
not a huge figure. He's He's a talking head of the Israeli government.
>> IS TOTALLY OKAY, I GUESS. WELL, OKAY. NO, I want to
bring you I want to bring
Hang on. Hang on. I would like him to answer my question. WHY
IS THAT CONSIDERED A TROPE? WHY IS IT CONSIDERED A TROPE TO BE
concerned about American soldiers during these endless nonsensical
wars? Why is that considered a trope? >> How many times
have you gone to Arlington and paid your respects to >> talking
to you, Conricus, you terrorist piece of crap. I'm talking to
the
>> Please keep the ad hominem down. I want
>> American soldiers Can we GO BACK TO THE ANSWER THE QUESTION.
Can I bring Can I bring some order to this, please? Now, Judge
Jonathan, let me conduct the the panel, please, cuz Glenn's been
waiting very patiently. Before I come to you, Glenn, I will give
you plenty of time to speak. I can promise you that. Um General,
just explain why you consider that to be a trope. And secondly,
I was really struck by this friendly fire incident, because I
can't remember I'm sure you will be able to correct me here,
but has it ever happened before that three American fighter jets
have all been downed in a friendly fire incident, apparently
here, by Kuwaiti forces, by mistake,
uh as they went over Kuwaiti airspace? Can Can you remember three
American fighter jets jets going down in friendly fire in one
incident?
And and I'm Also, if it's one incident, how did this
Do you know what I really think this could be? What What kind
of air defense does does Kuwait have American air defense, or
do they have some kind of like Soviet-era air defense? Like,
what's happening?
One incident, three planes. >> Sure, those Kuwaiti Where
are the other
Yeah, well, I know, but where are the other plane? Why aren't
any of the other planes in frame here, my wand? It's one incident.
Why Where are the other planes?
The soldiers that fired those shots will remember that for the
rest of their lives. Luckily, no. Like, to me, it seems like
a bunch of stuff got shot
But, I don't know Like, to me
I wouldn't be shocked if there was some sort of uh um like Could
it be electronic warfare in some Is it a Kuwaiti jet? Oh, was
it anti-air? It was Kuwaiti jet. Oh, that's weirder then. Wait,
how did he take down cuz Well, I think some Su-24s got shot down
the same day, right?
So, it might have just been
It could have easily just been Oh, right. It is I saw this. It's
fine. >> None of the soldiers were None of the airmen were
killed. They got out of their aircraft alive and relatively unhurt.
Um We call it the fog of war. Yeah. I I mean, in relation to
the the >> Why is it a trope? >> think it's a Yeah,
I I I think be fair to Annika's parent, just answer her question.
Why you view that as a trope, the what she I I'm I'm not going
to dignify it with a
Okay, this completely completely
completely ridiculous.
You just You just try to call it anti-Semitism. You say it's
a trope. You can't even remotely come close to to defending yourself.
You said something
Fantastic. Fantastic stuff. You just want to smear me with nonsensical
claims, but you can't even answer why you even believe in the
smear. What is the trope? You can't answer it, right? I'll tell
you why you are a total
No, no, no, I want to come back to
The general The general total hypocrite. Okay, the general Listen,
the general The general's chosen not to respond. That's his right.
I want to go to Glenn. Glenn, you've been very, very patiently.
Thank you. Um look, this is a story that's a lot of passion that's
going to run very high here. Glenn always looks whenever Glenn's
on a panel or something, he looks like he's in pain. Like, being
silent hurts him. He just always looks like he's in like like
psychic pain all the time. He's like got the one eye twitching.
It's just Um you know, I don't have I don't have all the answers
to what I think is going to happen here. It does to me bring
back a lot of bad memories from the Iraq war. You know, which
was started in many people's eyes who perpetrated it for the
best of intentions. Saddam was a bad guy doing bad things to
his people, killing many of them, running a ruthless regime,
possessing weapons of mass destruction, and he had to be stopped.
You know, I've been on this rodeo of rhetoric before, and it
feels to me like we're on a very similar path now, but Iran is
an altogether bigger and more difficult scenario than even Iraq
was. You know, you've got 220,000 220,000 revolutionary guard.
You have nearly a million regular army. You have many other paramilitaries.
You know, hundreds of thousands more. This idea that America
or Donald Trump has that by doing these strikes, you're going
to start a big revolution amongst the people on the ground. Um
you know, they've got to get past 1 and 1/2 million very heavily
armed people that will try and stop them. And we saw recently,
they stopped 30,000 of them by killing them. So, do you think
that the mission here is even achievable? And do you think what
has happened is legal?
Could you do like simpler Why do you He asked all of those questions
at the same time. I am glad, Piers, that we started the segment
with Mike Pence because he is an American elected official who
voted for the Iraq war in 2002, 2003, continued to defend it
for many years, and unlike many American politicians who did
that, who ended up saying they regretted it or it was a mistake,
Mike Pence to this very day believes that going into Iraq was
the right thing to do, and everything that he said in justification
and defense of this new
Dude, Mike Pence isn't a Christian Zionist, is he? Can I get
Can we get a temperature temperature check on that? Is Mike Pence
a Christian Zionist? Is your entire country a cult? Is like 30%
of your culture country in like a total cult? was exactly the
things that he and all the other American leaders who wanted
this war in 2002 and 2003 were saying then. But, it's not just
the Iraq war, it's also exactly what happened in Libya. President
Obama said, "Oh, don't worry, this isn't a regime change war,
it's just to protect the people of Benghazi." And then it ended
up being a regime change war that destroyed Libya. It's what
we did in Afghanistan where we were told, "Oh This is not true
at all. This is not true, Unionize. When I say Christian Zionist,
I don't mean Christian who is a Zionist. I have no problem with
Christians who are Zionists. I have problems with people who
have read some weird Armageddon propaganda into Christianity
and present that schism that doesn't make sense with like as
if it's a real Christian sect.
Like, it's I don't have a problem with Christians who are Zionists.
I have a problem with this this sect of Evan Evangelicalism
that apparently
is is just total propaganda to support anything Israel does.
It's [__] insane. Oh, we're just going in to get
Osama bin Laden, and then 20 years later, our troops leave, trillions
of dollars spent, huge numbers of dead, and the Taliban march
right back into power. And you can even go back to Vietnam where
we were lied into that war, lied through that war by many of
the same people who telling us now that we have to do this. It
is astounding to me that somebody like Mike Pence or so many
other people who lied to the public continuously, led our country
into disastrous wars one after the next, are now just speaking
as though none of it ever happened. It would be like as if a
journalist, I published eight or nine different fraudulent stories
with fake quotes and fake sources, and then the next day I woke
up and said, "Oh, I know I did those things in the past, but
I think I should still have credibility for you to listen to
my reporting today even though I did all of that." The other
point I want to make is I want to ask Jonathan cuz I mean, honestly,
it is very, very difficult. to confess, not just for me, but
for the world as as the poll show, to listen to an Israeli official
in an Israeli accent give lectures on the need to have compassion
for civilians after everything we just watched Israel do, vaporizing
tens
>> How dare you? How dare you? It's Greta Everybody's Greta
Thunberg today. You love to see it. Love Love Glenn Greenwald.
>> Israeli official in an Israeli accent give lectures
on the need to have compassion for civilians after everything
we just watched Israel do, vaporizing tens of thousands of people
in Gaza, all throughout the Middle East attacking countries.
But, since he is here, I do want to ask him. Jonathan, there's
a lot of reports in mainstream Western press about how the IDF
has built its primary military and intelligence structures not
just within key residential areas in Tel Aviv, but also underneath.
Is it true that the IDF has built key military and intelligence
targets within residential areas of Tel Aviv and beneath residential
targets in Tel Aviv the way that the Western media has continuously
reported? Is that actually true? Yeah, I can give a relatively
short and plain answer to it.
No, it's not >> surprising question. I've read some of
your reporting and you seem like an informed guy. Uh but
yes, the IDF headquarters, referred to as the Kirya, is indeed
located in Tel Aviv. Uh it is surrounded by civilian buildings
and inside the headquarter,
not underneath civilians, but underneath the headquarter itself
is a bunker, which is not a revolutionary concept of militaries.
Well, I just thought if you I thought you're supposed to distinguish
those things. Is it not possible that the Iranians are trying
to hit And that bunker is a few stories below ground. It is Its
name is indeed the Zion Citadel. And that is where some of the
Israeli officers, generals conduct military operations from.
I suppose some of the strikes, if not all of the strikes that
are ongoing in Iran today, are managed from there. When Iran
targeted that location,
they've targeted it now. They have targeted it in in the past,
and Hezbollah has targeted it in the past, and so have many others.
You actually never heard anybody in Israel definitely not a anybody
official
"You know, that isn't okay, and
it's not a military target." It is a military target. We cannot
move Tel Aviv out of the way, and the base is probably too big
to move out of the way. And if it is
But, you don't do it through official channels, right? That would
be the
Like, you just let people say it. You don't do it through official
channels. You just let other people say it for you, right? hit,
then it is on Israel because it is a military target.
Do Do they not Do they come out and when when somebody in their
media publishes that that was like a an attack on civilians?
Do they come out and correct and go, "Actually, that that building
that got hit is within like X meters of a military target, so
technically, that's not a war crime at all. It's totally justified
for them to have taken that shot at civilians." Does the IDF
come out and correct that, or do they just sit back and let other
people do their dirty work for them? But, there's a very big
difference here between doing that, having a properly
marked and disclosed location, which is the IDF base. Everybody
knows that it's there. And doing what our enemies Uh I've got
to But, you guys have to understand, okay? Yeah, he gives these
His answers are all really good. It's hard to go after this guy
because he is incredibly well media trained. He is like very,
very, very good about giving the answers that that are going
to sound the best to everybody. He's He's smart. He's He's very
good at his job. I've never taken that away from Con Reikes.
Not when I was more pro-Zionist, not now, okay? He does give
really good answers. Like he's he's He's giving answers that
are difficult to pick apart or point out why they're bad. >> which
is hide underneath and between the civilian population, disguised
as civilians and using civilians as human shields. There are
no civilians above the base used as human shields. And there
are no civilians that are told to be in a certain location so
that our enemies won't strike. >> Okay. A because Okay.
Let's go back to the question. Yeah. Pay Pay Pay attention You've
asked your question. Can I just Can I just make one quick point?
Can I just make one quick point about the moral aspect that that
you raised? You know, you said um none of us should be mourning
a vicious dictator. And the one thing that the two quick things
I will say about that is, you know, we were told that about Saddam
Hussein, we were told that about Muammar Gaddafi. Certainly in
Libya we were told, "Oh, Muammar Gaddafi is dead. That's certainly
a good thing." What came after in Libya was some of the worst
most nightmarish dystopia that the world has seen in the past
50 years, certainly far worse than what it had under Gaddafi.
And I think a lot of this depends on what succeed Why is she
shaking her head? He's just saying something that's factually
true. Why is she just shaking her head? succeeds in Iran? Is
it going to be this incredibly destroyed state balkanized with
anarchy where ISIS and Al-Qaeda can fill the power vacuum as
they did with the Wait. No, I think that's actually a good question
ask though, isn't it, Dung
Like basically the entire reason they thought the school might
have been hit or the reason they would like basically pass it
off as fine is cuz it's close-ish to a military target. It's
not like a worthless question. invasion of Iraq? Is it going
to be an even worse tyrant like the Shah of Iran was or some
other worse militias and factions? And then the other point is
it's a little bit I mean, it's already worse. Just in case anybody
was curious, it's already worse. The leader they picked is about
the
They picked like the the massive hardliners their new leader.
Like the the guy who's like raised in this and embraces every
aspect of it and is on top of that, if if he's corrupt in any
way, it's like to promote additional cruelty. Like they basically
picked Ramsey Bolton for their leader, okay? You're curious?
That's the guy they picked now.
Yeah, the head of the secret police
That's the guy they picked.
Very cool. >> hard to hear the United States and Great
Britain and other countries I sure I sure hope they at least
take this guy out, too. That would be really Oh, we're doing
this for the moral reason that we want to cleanse Iran of tyranny
when our closest allies and partners in that region that we prop
up and give military technology and spying technology are at
least as savage and brutal dictatorships as Iran is. Saudi Arabia,
Egypt, the Emirates, going throughout the rest of the world to
Uganda, Rwanda, we Hold on. Glenn is going through the whole
Why is Rubio here and here?
It's double Rubio.
Very weird. Okay. It's fine. It's just >> dictatorships.
We prop up tyrannies all the time. Think it's very hard to make
a moral case, especially as you're bombing civilian places all
throughout Iran, that we somehow are doing this because we want
to bring freedom and democracy to the Iraqi people the Iranian
people. The last time we did change the government of Iran, we
imposed a horrific dictator on them for 20 30 years called the
Shah of Iran. And now we want to do it with his son. So these
moral questions are more much more complex than is the Ayatollah
good or a bad guy.
Okay, Goldie you were rolling your eyes at Glenn. We should have
no moral reasons at all. Again, there is no That's fantastic.
Unfortunately, that's clearly not true cuz you can't support
any logical decision-making. There's no logical decision-making
happening. I agree with THIS OLD GUY. THERE should be no moral
decisions happening here. They're your politicians. It should
be does this serve America? Yes or no? But every single question
they Every single thing they've described to you is a moral judgment
on the IRGC or the Iranian Sorry, the uh Islamic regime the Islamic
Republic. Which you can make those judgments, but they're using
those to try to sway the public, not logical reasons.
no morality in our negotiations
last Thursday for no nukes, no missiles,
uh and no proxies. And I don't think if we start getting into
the moral regime change everything you're describing, Glenn,
if we're trying to get into another Iraq, that's the mission
creep we don't want to see. We are now using the military force
to achieve the end state that our negotiations
weren't able to do. And candidly, I also agree with you that
we shouldn't uh completely wipe out the uh leadership of the
country. I I I LBJ, Lyndon Baines Johnson once said, uh he's
an SOB, but he's our SOB. We now have Darcy Rodriguez as one
of our SOBs.
We have Ahmed al-Sharaa as one of our uh SOBs.
Manuel Noriega [clears throat] in Panama Make regime change great
again. Let's go, boys.
Make regime change great again.
Guess what, guys? You know what the real problem was with the
CIA changing all of those regimes? It's that we weren't transparent
about it. So now, guess what? We do a regime change. That's actually
America's modus operandi. You don't like us, you don't give us
whatever we want, boom, you're dead. Oh, you You think you can
like nationalize that industry? Boom, you're
The The real problem was that we just didn't hide it Or so we
hid it before. We didn't let you know. was one of our SOBs.
The fact remains is we ought to have a very limited mission which
is simply to use military force to compel
Iran back to the negotiating table for them to give up their
missiles, their nukes, and their proxies. We can do it now. We
won't be able to do it when they have a nuclear weapon.
I I just I agree with that. I wish everybody worse candid is
the general about the absence of a moral case here.
Yeah, I agree with you. I thought it was quite refreshing. Let
me go to Goldie Goldie Gamarra, you've been waiting patiently.
Um you were rolling your eyes at Glenn Greenwald there, why?
You know, just this whole communist his revisionist propaganda
about the 1953,
you know,
>> Can I just say Wait, what the [__]
Islamocommies.
She's doing the Islamocommie cope, okay?
It's like Dude, Glenn is lost. Glenn is totally lost. coup
Um Mosaddegh was a communist traitor. He was funded by the Soviets.
Uh the Shah of Iran was actually installed in 1941. That's when
he ascended the throne. And uh you know, everyone loves to talk
about 1953, but no one ever talks about 1906 when we had the
constitutional monarchy. Uh sorry, the constitutional revolution
which led to the first democratically elected parliament of Iran.
So as of 1906 up until 1979,
Iran was a constitutional monarchy, very similar to England.
In fact, Pierce uh the Queen of England visited um uh Iran in
the early 1960s for a 10-day state visit because that's how much
uh the Shah of Iran and Queen Elizabeth were close friends. Bro,
this is like totally
This is totally insane. When the Queen visited, they were not
a democracy in any way before. They were a democracy for a little
bit. The Shah consolidated power. That's what the 1953 coup was.
Was him consolidating power onto himself. >> Now with respect
to what's happening today, first of all, I just want to With
help from the United Kingdom. Where's that queen from? Oh, the
United Kingdom? Oh, right. Oh.
The Queen was somebody who who probably was very much knowledgeable
and understood that they were putting that guy on the throne
for their interests. Oh, cool. say, you know, thank you to the
United States, thank you to Israel for everything that they're
doing. Um we Iranians were so grateful. And
I can tell you that this has been one of the most amazing weekends,
not just for me, but for Iranians in occupied Iran and around
the world. You know, hearing the news of of the death of Khamenei,
that's like the equivalent of of hearing the news of the death
of Hitler. It's just something that we have been waiting for
for so long. And uh all I can say is thank you so much. God bless
America. I'm Israel high. We cannot wait until until Iran I'M
ISRAEL HIGH. YES, THANK YOU. is free and uh we can welcome Americans
and Israelis back to Iran with open arms and uh be the allies
that we were prior to 1979.
Um little tip.
Little tip. Just little tip. If If Israel is funding these monarchists
as I've already suspected, as we've already got a little evidence
for, don't let them Don't attach them to you. I'm Israel high.
Like That undermines everything she's doing here. What are you
What is this, man?
What is this? Okay, and I I I think you know,
I look, everyone would love that to be the case. I think it's
extremely difficult to get there. Israel funds the MEK historically.
I'm sure they fund any opposition to the Shah. Sorry, to to Khamenei,
to the Islamic Republic. I'm sure they do. Which by the way,
I don't even care about that. I Of course they do. I'm just saying
that like
when these people are speaking now, I have reason to doubt their
sincerity. I have reason to doubt what they're
Uh as we will probably see,
your uh your uh colleague Cenk Uygur, who you referenced at the
top of the show, you know, he did a tweet which even I recall.
I like Cenk a lot, but um you know, he he he called the Ayatollah
courageous cuz he hadn't gone on his knees to Israel. Um did
you agree? I mean, do you think the Ayatollah Khamenei was a
courageous man? Well, he never capitulated to the Israelis. And
uh we live under a government Dude, look how look how psyched
Cenk Uygur is about this process. >> man? Well, he never
capitulated to the Israelis and we live Yeah, I feel like I I
saw just two little expressions there. He's normally
a sphinx, okay? But he's like, "You're You're going to have to
answer this question." I didn't answer the question that was
hard. Now you have to answer a question that's hard. And actually
navigate it well. >> under a government where regardless
of which party is in power
is on its knees on behalf of Israel. So, I understand what he's
talking about. He's talking about government leaders a country's
leader in the case of Iran as much as I did not agree with the
Ayatollah. I'm not a religious person and I certainly don't like
extremism or supremacy of any kind. Uh the fact of the matter
is he didn't embarrass his people by getting down on his knees
to pleasure Israel as our leaders here in the United States do.
So, I understand Donald Trump is a Thank you, Anna. It had to
be said. It really did have to be said. Okay. >> And the
point that he was trying to make and I think if you talk to a
lot of Americans, they are embarrassed by the fact that our leadership
rarely represents our best interests and seems to prioritize
the best interests of Israel in every instance and I think that
what we're experiencing right now is a good example of that.
But this is an Ayatollah who only
>> Dude. Uh Piers did not Piers is just like trying to
really ignore it, okay? He's just trying to ignore it. Henna
Kissesbury and
the alarm clock. >> weeks ago slaughtered 30,000
of his people to repress them from >> That number's not
confirmed. So, you're regurgitating it. Oh, bad answer.
Bad answer.
Bad answer cuz it doesn't matter if that number's confirmed.
I thought we weren't moralizing this. It doesn't matter. You
could You should just throw Khomeini under the bus. Yeah, he's
monstrous. He's oppressing his
But being monstrous and oppressing your people, we've decided
already based on Iraq, based on Libya, is not enough of a pretext
for regime change.
Especially not totally uncontrolled chaotic regime change. It
is very questionable, Piers. Where'd you get that number from?
>> Well, how many do you Okay, well, how many do you think
were killed? We don't know the exact number. But to say that
30,000 people were slaughtered during those like short weeks
is ridiculous to me. Uh Iran is specifically saying >> widely
How many
Oh, a lot of people got slaughtered. They're pretty repressive
bad. They're pretty old boy and I don't do that. Well, have been
killed and it's around
We don't know what the exact number is. But you really I don't
know when that report got published, but it's at least 7. We
think 30,000 people were killed?
You're not going to question that
Well, I just I'm curious if you don't think it's 30,000, how
many do you think it was?
I don't know the exact number.
No one knows the exact number.
Yeah, it's it do be hard to go up against these people. They
be pushing you emotionally and then But my point is you don't
know the number. How do you >> point but Well, hang on.
Hang on. Hang on. [laughter] Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang
on. Hang on. >> You don't have to agree with the REGIME
IN IRAN. I'VE SAID MULTIPLE TIMES [laughter] YOU DON'T have to
agree Hang on for a second. I've said multiple times I don't
agree or like the regime in Iran. That doesn't mean that doesn't
mean that it's untrue that they never capitulated to what Israel
demanded of them. WHEREAS HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, WE LITERALLY
still bow down to them and use our treasure on behalf of Israel.
That's She should never have commented. She should never have
said if she wasn't certain. She should never have said what the
number was there cuz it wasn't
chill. Chill. I don't know who you are. I've never seen you before.
I should actually look. Does this guy have an avatar? Thank god
he's anonymous. Never seen this guy before, but
Is it chill? Chill.
Um I think 7,000 is the minimum number. It's probably quite a
bit higher.
I don't know if it's 30.
Like I mean I somewhere between 7 and and 30
is probably at least 10, 12 at minimum, right? Which is crazy.
Like it's already crazy that it's at least 10 or 12 at
in my opinion. And that was in like what? 3 days a couple days?
It's crazy, man. >> point that Cenk was trying to make.
And I think it's a pretty accurate point.
>> Okay, you can make that point. I'm questioning the Hang
on one second, please. I'm questioning the use of the word courageous
about Uh this always happens. Whenever you Whenever you do this,
you could describe Listen, if you
if you say like, "Well, say what you will about the Nazis, but
they were an industrious people." It's like, "What do you mean
by industrious?" If you use like a word for something that is
already evil that is anything but that is anything but like totally
condemning, people just freak the [__]
She already said in the way the way in the point Cenk was making,
the way they're saying courageous is like, "You know, he knew
he was going to get [__] and he did it anyway." Right?
He's more courageous than Hitler. We could say that at least.
Oh, dude, that
That was some total point. Who was the who put "I guess Hitler
was courageous then" under that tweet? What are we talking >> A ruthless
despotic monster. Oh, it was Erudite. It was Erudite. >> And
you know, I'm curious why you are so confident it's not 30,000
people who were killed, but you have no idea how many people
were killed. How can you be sure it wasn't 30,000? >> I
don't know how many people were killed. You don't know how many
people were killed. So, to say that the highest number you've
heard
is questionable to say the least. Especially when you know that
Mossad was on the ground. There were armed terrorists on the
ground. You know I'm pretty confident Mossad was on the ground
cuz uh-huh
US former US diplomat said as much. But
I don't think Mossad was looking to kill those people. And not
only that, and the IRGC is pretty happy to televise the fact
that they were doing these crackdowns, okay, to intimidate people.
Like this is what they wanted to do. They wanted to crack down
on these protests and intimidate people.
Okay? They They wanted to do that. So, I don't really have a
lot of reason to suspect that the Jews, you know, pushed them
to kill these people. All right?
Hmm, what else is there here?
Oh, I was looking for it to make another point. Oh, she said
something else to >> security forces number you've heard
is questionable to say the least. Especially when you know that
Mossad was on the ground. There were armed terrorists on the
ground. You know security forces were killed during those shootings.
Look, the hyena's laughing again. Anyway, but to just regurgitate
the number that is being perpetuated by the Israelis is ridiculous
to me. We don't know the exact number. So, rather than regurgitate
it, Listen, Anna Anna's going through red pill psychosis, okay?
Anna's worldview is changing very rapidly with updated information
that that necessitates like an openness to new information in
a way that is never good for you, okay?
Anna Anna needs to get through this part. She's at like the bottom
of this this curve right now. Okay, she needs to start getting
back to normal, all right? Don't just remember Don't just remember
Sorry, don't just just trust everything you say everything you
hear. Don't just trust everything you hear. It's like anti-Israel.
Got to be a little more discerning, all right? We can say that
there was high high casualty count. We don't know the exact number.
It's that simple. But you You used to regurgitate numbers and
Hang on. Hang on one second, please. Hang on. Let me Please let
me finish. You did regurgitate, Anna, with respect all the numbers
given to you by the Hamas-run health authority of Palestinian
casualties without any
I think the Hamas-run authority is like by far the most like
widely accepted numbers, aren't they? Like the Hamas health authority
for the numbers in Gaza, I think is the one that is most It was
at some point the most trusted. Different from like other propaganda
sources for Hamas, but the actual like Gaza health ministry or
whatever, those were trustworthy
People people literally would come up and go, "Oh, you're just
going to trust it." It's like Bro, everybody uses that number.
We talk about It's confirmed by the Israelis, Piers.
>> That was confirmed by the Israelis. You know that, right?
Dude, this is so funny. Uh Piers is totally right. Who counted
Anna out? Who is Who is doubting Anna? I'm checking the chat.
Who is doubting Anna? Who is doubting
Who is doubting?
Oh, Joob thought ANNA WAS RIGHT. OH, JOOB.
OH, NO.
Best Anna clip was telling that person to shut the to shut the
[__] up, [__]
I don't see anybody else doubting Anna. And everybody else believed
in Anna. Everybody else. They were They were They were
They were broadly confirmed eventually. But But my point is My
point is you seem [laughter] very Well, hey. WELL, WHY DID PIERS
SAY THAT THEN? If he knew that or is he getting Is he Have somebody
in his ear or
Does Does he have somebody in his ear or how do you He's like,
"Well, they were kind of confirmed eventually."
They were because the Hamas health ministry is very very careful.
Here's my point. Anna, here's my Um Wait, Dumb Devil, do you
think she's saying I trust the Israelis or do you Do you Do you
think she's saying that even the person even the people most
likely to dispute this actually confirmed it? Which one do you
think she's doing?
Cuz I got a feeling Anna broadly doesn't trust Israelis.
I have a feeling she's making a slightly different argument there,
no? My point. [laughter] You I don't understand your your apparent
keenness to downplay the ruthlessness of the Ayatollah or Cenk's
enthusiasm.
>> Joob, you need to go watch the first start of this section,
okay?
America confirmed that there's basically no reason to believe
an uprising would be successful. Um Am- American senators literally
came out and said, "We want to be really careful about not encouraging
some kind of uprising cuz they would get
Basically everything you were hypothesizing has been categorically
blown the [__] out.
But anyway, we got to correct you. >> it. I'm just not
going to regurgitate Israeli propaganda as you're doing right
now, Piers.
Piers, can I have a >> Jonathan Conricus. Yeah, Jonathan,
yeah. Yeah, I mean, since my country has been I'm I'm just pointing
out that you like totally bit the you totally swallowed the propaganda.
Okay, the monarchist propaganda totally propped up by Israel.
These are the kinds of people you've been listening to. This
doesn't This doesn't exist. You're encouraging people
That's what you're doing. been mentioned so many times by uh
people of questionable moral backgrounds and motivations. I'd
like to say a few things about my perspective. >> You cherry-picked
a few Dems to make your point.
Do you think that's all I did, bad ABB? Do you think I cherry-picked?
I'm totally fine arguing this with
I'm totally fine. If you want to argue this, hop in the Discord.
We would totally argue this. Should be very easy. Coming from
a guy who defends the slaughter of the mass slaughter of the
>> I didn't interrupt you. I didn't >> Well, I'm
interrupting you, so stop. >> like a little girl like you
did. So, please, stay in your lane. I didn't interrupt you and
stay out of my >> up. No, I don't have to hurry up and
I don't take orders from you, Anna. And I will speak because
you've spoken a lot and you've said a lot of nonsense and I want
to give my perspective on what's going on. And it's ridicu-
You don't control me. I'll speak what I
So, anyway, I wasn't able to debunk anything I said though. >> to
frame this as something that is whereby Israel is in the driving
seat. This is an American-led operation It is. >> where
there are clearly defined goals by the US that serve US strategic
interest. That's one
What are the strategic goals of the United States that they had
before this operation was undertaken?
Which Which are they? Anna's got him here. Anna's got him Anna's
got him dead to rights. If she's asking that question, yesterday,
if she just asks, "What are those strategic goals?" This guy
will contradict the president today, no matter what he answers.
set of issues that is separate from the ones that is relevant
to Israel. There's a lot of overlap, but here's the Israeli perspective.
We live in our national homeland, which we have about 3,000 years
of documented and archaeological history that connects us to
it. Yet we are surround
surrounded by about five or six different terrorist organizations
that are funded by Iran, by the Islamic regime, who all operate
against Israel, killing our civilians, harassing our people,
infringing on our sovereignty, and all
conniving and trying to bring about the destruction of the state
of Israel. These organizations, Hamas, Islamic Jihad, Hezbollah,
former Iranian proxies in Syria, the Houthis in Yemen, Iranian
proxies in Iraq, are all funded
Is Is PIJ also funded by Iran? I didn't know that. I wouldn't
have thought Iran would fund multiple places multiple interests
by orchestrated by and armed by Iran.
Who is the Who are the Qataris funding? I thought the Qataris
were funding a bunch of terrorism.
Who are the Qataris funding?
I thought they were funding Hamas and PIJ. What the [__]
And the overarching idea is to annihilate the state of Israel.
The Islamic Republic has an outspoken goal, which they have been
pursuing for the better part of 30 years, to destroy the state
of Israel. They're not just saying it, they are doing it and
they have been enacting. They have been squandering the resources
of the Iranian people. They have been mismanaging the funds of
Iran, neglecting Iranian people, and they have been prioritizing
militants and terrorists in Um no, I'm talking about funding
going into Gaza, Don Devil. I don't think anybody's accusing
the Saudis of funding Gaza. Well, I guess maybe back like in
the '80s, '90s, maybe. >> in Gaza, in Lebanon, in Judea
and Samaria, in Syria, in Iraq, in Yemen, and other places around
the world. Why? Because they have this feverish focus
Jub Jub Jub Jub, just as a little fun fact, you know that the
US is literally arming as their first choice as a militia in
the region, the people who would shoot the Shah in the head the
second they saw him, right? The Kurds. The The There is nowhere
he is more reviled than in than in the Kurdish Iranian population.
And that's the first choice for who they're arming, the Kurds.
Did Jub hear about this one yet? I just want to know. This This
sick focus on Israel on trying to destroy and annihilate the
Jewish state when Iranians
Source on on the US wanting to arm the Kurds?
I believe that's confirmed. Hold on, let me let me look.
Read this from the The Cradle right
Okay, we have what else?
Um this from the from Oh, I'll hold on.
CIA working to arm Kurdish forces to spark uprising in Iran,
sources say.
Very cool. Very cool. Very cool.
Very cool.
Very cool. Very cool. say, "We want to destroy Israel." We listen
to it and we So claimed. Gotcha.
I believe Trump has explicitly said so as well, but I'm not totally
sure. I'm pr- I'm pretty
pretty sure. take it with real value
But apparently apparently this isn't >> because we understand
that they're serious. And I'll finish with this uh Piers. Ooh,
hold on. Is this What is
Imperium first, weird.
Weird Warhammer [__] Okay. Dan Crenshaw just lost
his congressional seat. Congressional seat. Oh, boy. Dan Crenshaw's
out, guys.
Dan Crenshaw is out.
Love this clip. >> ALL RIGHT, I'M DAN CRENSHAW.
CAN YOU PLEASE RESPECT ISRAEL?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST CLIPS, MAN. The motivation for
Israel is we want to live in our homeland without Iranian terror
organizations, without Iranian ballistic missiles, and without
Iranian nuclear weapons that are aimed at them. include the West
Bank and in my in southern Lebanon. I'm going to come to you.
I'm going to come Yeah, it's the Don, right? And Gaza. Judea
and Samaria. Yes, if you're asking
Judea and Samaria. about Judea and Samaria. If you ask about
Judea and Samaria, yes, that is part of the Jewish >> world
thinks it's not yours, which the whole world believes is not
yours. You're the expansionist state. You're the aggressor. >> No, we're
not expansionist.
We are a people that came back to our homeland.
That's right. Okay. Okay. And we came
We're not We're not expansionist. Everybody has stolen from us.
We're just accepting back what they stole from us, guys. Come
on, man. Okay, don't talk Jonathan. You've had a good Jonathan,
I gave you I gave you good time, Jonathan. I want to let Glenn
finish with a response to what you just Uh Glenn. I mean, this
is the victim mentality. The whole world is against us. We just
want to be a peaceful country. The reality
>> of the is it's not the position of the Iranian government
that their border should be expanded, it's the position of the
Israeli government that their border should be radically expanded,
including into places and in ways that the United States government
for decades under both Democratic and Republican leadership has
said is a direct threat to American
>> Before Before
Before Khamenei's son is is gone, get this on a flight to Iran
immediately.
I can't stand anymore, okay? Iranian government said their border
should be expanded, it's the position of the Israeli government
that their border should be radically expanded, including into
places and in ways that the United States government for decades
under
Republican leadership has said is a direct threat to American
interests. Settlements in the West Bank
Dude, I
Is this guy Is this guy trying to say that like Israel wants
more land? Dude, Glenn asks Jonathan Conricus, "Hey, John, do
you believe in greater Israel?" and he's like, "Yes, Judea and
Samaria are our homeland." And Glenn goes and he starts explaining
how Judea They think Judea and Samaria is their homeland and
they're going to expand there. And she's like, "Is this guy just
spewing anti-Semitic conspiracy theories live on Piers Morgan?"
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Bro, Jonathan Conricus sits there and he's like, "Yeah, that's
our shit."
And we're not expansionist, but that was our [__]
That was promised to us. That's ours. We get that, okay?
>> annexing the West Bank into places and in ways that
the United States government for decades under both Democratic
and Republican leadership has said is a direct threat to American
interests. Settlements in the West Bank, annexing the West Bank,
moving into Gaza, bombing Lebanon, expanding into Lebanon, This
is the fanatical expansionist nuclear-armed dangerous power in
the Middle East that the United States pays for, that American
soldiers die for, and this narrative used to be dominant. Yes,
we're expanding. Yes, they said it was bad. Yet we're going to
do it anyway. And this is the the group that Americans are dying
for. No, America makes their own decisions. We don't control
We don't do that. Come on, man. >> the West, the people
have seen the true face of Israel and US support for Israel over
the past couple of years, and you see it in polling, not just
in the United States, but around the world, that people see Israel
and increasingly the United States as the rogue countries that
are the true danger to the world. As an American, I wish that
weren't true. I'm doing everything possible in my power to change
it. A lot of other people are as well, but that is the reality
for now.
Okay, Goldie, uh just very quickly, cuz we've run out of time,
but Polymarket are predicting
uh in relation to the question, will the Iranian re- regime fall
by June the 30th? They currently have it at a 41% chance. Uh
with over $5 million in that market. That's a lot of money going
down
Piers got the sponsorship before I did. [__] on this
Iranian regime falling by the end of June. Do you share that
I mean, I don't really pay attention to Polymarket, but uh I'm
going to tell you, Piers, that I have a feeling that the Islamic
regime is going to fall uh by the Persian New Year, spring equinox.
That's my prediction, March 20th.
And General Kim, what what would be your quick response to that?
I don't think it's going to fall. They've Laura Jani has already
said he's going to crack down. They brought back Waheedi who
founded the Iranian Revolutionary Guards Quds Force in 1988.
Uh at this point, there seems no fracturing in the IRGC
or in the Basij. And uh but it could happen. Things
>> May I buy you a beer in Iran when it's free? When Iran
is free, you uh you have to owe me a a trip to Iran so I can
buy you a beer and tell you I told you so. >> forward to
it. And look, nothing would make me happier than for Iran to
I I swear to God, I I cannot watch I cannot watch a John laugh
and nod over here without just like When Iran is free, you uh
you have to owe me a a trip to Iran so I can buy you a beer and
tell you I told you so. >> forward to it. And look, nothing
would make me the totally insane cult indoctrination that he's
just like nodding along for. I'm sorry. It's like it's crazy,
okay? It's crazy. >> Iran to be a civil society, democratic
society that abides by human rights. Uh this is a strong dictator.
And it's well and it's got a pretty
uh So, this guy's been against Anna and Glenn the whole time.
And even this is the one line he just can't like allow to go
by is you've got like a entrenched, totally decentralized regime
there that is still got all of their on the ground weapons, all
their ground forces. They got their weapons. The Basij is intact.
The Quds Force is intact. They They're bringing back former people,
probably people who are exiled for being too extreme.
This regime's probably not getting ousted at all. I I would ask
you, Goldie, I wish it was the case. Tell me how we get the IRGC,
the Basij, and the
to lay down their weapons.
Well, many of them are already laying down their weapons. It's
President Trump's peace through strength uh strategy. A lot of
videos have have actually come out today, General, from we get
the IRGC,
the Basij, and the
to lay down their Listen, I don't like to engage in any sort
anything that could even be hinted at as anti-Semitism. But is
John Conricus doing like a mind control spell? He's like nodding
along and she's saying all the things he wants her to say. Well,
many of them are already laying down their weapons. It's President
Trump's peace through strength uh strategy. A lot of videos have
actually come out This guy doesn't move the whole thing, and
then she starts spewing propaganda that's totally unfounded,
and this guy just like starts nodding along.
today, General. Um showing
Nothing to do with him being By the way, it's Israeli mind control
tech, okay? Somehow, if I just say the word Israeli, if I if
I use that word, magically, it's just no longer anti-Semitic.
Apparently, other people think this.
That's like way better somehow. >> a number of defections.
And uh for those that who do not want to lay down their weapons,
the only option is to exterminate them. And we Iranians are very
grateful that United States and Israel are getting rid of all
of these um Islamic terrorists that have occupied our country
for the What's the unfounded propaganda
that you can dislodge this regime without boots on the ground?
Totally unfounded propaganda. That's just the way it is. I Listen,
if you just want to sit in the background as somebody's watching
this, you want to cheer as random like terrorist fundamentalists
get blown up, and you're fine with like your tax dollars being
spent purely to just enjoyably blow up terrorists,
If that's fine with you, then that's
But obviously, this regime
is kind of sitting pretty.
Unless Unless Donald Trump breaks his solemn vow to his own people
and decides to put boots on the ground, okay?
Otherwise, it seems like it's not really a problem for for them.
Well, sorry, it's a problem. Like they're
But they're used to being I truly believe the IRGC, or not even
the IRGC, I truly believe the Islamic Republic expected to like
reckon with the West
decades ago.
They're probably shocked they were able to build up as much as
they have.
Do you know what I'm saying? Like I think they thought they were
going to start getting bombed and attacked way before this. The
fact that it's taken this long is probably like shocking to them.
You know what I'm saying? Oh, I never said boots on the ground
won't happen, Jube. I never once said that. But you understand
that that is then Americans dying for Israel, right? The one
thing that Donald Trump promised wouldn't happen, happening.
At that point, like I do think you can impeach Donald Trump.
I do think you should actually be calling to impeach Donald Trump.
I think people should be protesting the streets and saying get
this guy out of here. He doesn't represent us. He represents
some other people, okay? He represents some other people.
But people have to start saying this Like if if Fuentes and Tucker
aren't saying this now, like we need to impeach this person,
we will primary anybody who supports this, boots on the ground
is our red line, we will immediately be primarying anybody who
who supports this, we will get you out of office, you will never
ever be a politician in this country again. If that's not where
the line is, right? For these people,
then I don't know there is no line. Sadly, MAGA doesn't agree.
Are you sure? Last I saw, like 75% of people don't support this
operation to begin with. What do you think the polling's like
for boots on the ground? Unfortunately for MAGA, this is the
one fracture they have is they had a whole civil war what, 5
months ago? Five-ish months ago, okay? They had this whole civil
war thing where it was Nick Fuentes and Tucker Carlson saying,
"Yeah, we do have a problem with Israel. Israel's way too much
influence. They're breaking apart our party, our country. It's
[__] up. They want us to go to war with Iran, right?"
And the Republicans all stood on business there and said, "You're
out of your mind. We would never do that. WE WOULD NEVER do that.
You're out of your
That'll never happen, right?"
And unfortunately,
that has now come to
So, all of these people who were You have validated completely
the world views of Tucker Carlson, Nick Fuentes.
Okay? You have validated their world views within this right-wing
like um I guess influence sphere. You validated them. They are
your thought leaders now. They are the smartest people, okay?
I'm sorry. That's what you've done. That's the bed you made.
Now you get to lie in it. last 47 years, cuz ultimately, you
cannot negotiate with terrorists who Unfortunately, Moody Morgan,
you don't see it.
Trump doesn't lead the cults.
It is a cult.
Trump is not the head of it in the way he thinks he is. I'm going
to be proven out on this, by the way. He will lose control of
that cult. There's a reason he always stays friendly with Fuentes,
with Tucker, right? There's a reason he doesn't go after them
personally. There's a reason even though Tucker said some crazy
[__] about him, he's never gone after Tucker.
Who is? There's not one leader right It's basically shifted away
from Trump because Trump is increasingly doing [__]
like this. to chant death to America and death to Israel. So,
uh Goldie, Goldie, I I I think Goldie, I hope you're right. I
pray you're right. I would love to see that. I'm just pessimist.
That's okay, General. >> Okay, I've got to leave it there.
You owe me a beer in Iran. >> it there.
Uh I think we'd all like a beer at the end of this if there was
peace and prosperity for everyone involved. That would be a wonderful
uh pipe dream. Uh sadly, I think we're a long way off that. But
thank you all to my panel very much. Uh I'm joined now by Naftali
Bennett, the former Israeli Prime Minister. Uh Naftali Bennett,
welcome back to Uncensored.
Um a lot of people believe that what we're seeing here is the
culmination of Benjamin Netanyahu's
40-year dream, which is the dismantling of the uh of the Iranian
regime. Um and that it's more Ooh, it's Naftali Bennett, the
guy who Turkey is Hamas. It's him.
It's the Turkey is Hamas guy. Amazing. Amazing stuff. Okay.
Let's see.
Vote Voters oppose grounds uh oppose ground troops in Iran.
Okay, do we have anything that's like totally just everybody?
I guess it's right here. Bro, you get your country is totally
infiltrated, dude. And that America has been sucked into supporting
this, and that already what we're seeing is a slightly out of
control situation, which could, if we're not very careful here,
lead to a full-blown war in the Middle East. What is your response
to that? >> Does Donald Trump seem to you as someone who
will be dragged into something he doesn't want to do?
100% Oh, yeah. 1,000% yeah.
Uh I would say knowing him, no. But, I also think that Benjamin
Netanyahu has clearly been very persuasive
to Donald Trump in uh the way that he is now gone after Iran.
He's taken the not not the nuclear option, that would be too
ironic. He's taken the maximum
Um if you guys don't know who Naftali Bennett is, Naftali Bennett
is probably the most likely if Benjamin Netanyahu steps down,
I believe Naftali Bennett would inherit that coalition.
Yair Lapid is the guy on the other side, is the more left-wing
candidate. But, I do believe that Naftali Bennett would probably
inherit like some centrist center-right coalition, right? Is
Is Naftali Bennett far right? I don't think he's really far right
in Israel,
Uh uh
option he could Well, unfortunately, he was literally full dumb
devil just on the facts,
right? That Israel
that that there's no planning that went into this on the US the
USA's part, that they got caught with their pants down with Israel
going in, knowing that Israel knowing as well that the result
of their attack would be strikes on Americans. America had to
go, right? It wasn't his idea. It's probably not his idea. He
was dragged along.
Probably his own advisors said, "If they're going, we have to
go."
Now, if he's too much of a [__] to come out and say
that that happened and and to denounce Israel for it, then what
can you do? take in terms of a full-blown attack on the Iranian
regime. He's dismantled many of the top people, but it does beg
the question, and what does victory look like here? Well, Israel
doesn't drag anyone and allies don't drag each other into anything.
Allies work together towards a shared goal, and the goal is to
remove Iran as a nuclear threat to the world. Unfortunately,
after the June
12-day war, Iran resumed with full
moving their nuclear facilities under a huge mountain called
Pikes Peak Mountain, which is way deeper than Fordow, and it's
immune immune to any sort of bomb. Not only that, they doubled
down on production of ballistic missiles that can reach Israel,
Europe, and later on intercontinental ballistic missiles that
can reach the United States. And later on, like and later on.
I'm just curious, like Iran must have had that other facility
or something, right? I assume it's like really difficult. This
is just me, okay? I assume something really hard to get like
in this world is one, uranium,
and two, the level of precision centrifuge and systems around
that that are required to enrich that uranium to weapons degree.
Weapons weapons grade to make it weapons grade uranium. I assume
these things are like really quite difficult to get.
Oh, so they have uranium in the country. Okay, okay. Well, that
solves one
But, I'm saying the the technology to go and build these things
up, that it would take a long time to slowly build these to import
these things, especially under the restrictions they're under,
Where Where are they consistently getting all of this stuff?
You cannot build a a nuclear program covertly. Yeah, I wouldn't
think so. I just I I feel like if
if you're going to strike one of these
it's going to take years, right? Centrifuges were previously
sabotaged every 4 years or so. I do remember that. We all remember
Stuxnet, very cool, very cool. Listen, we listen to these people.
We listen to what they say. They say that America is the big
Satan, Israel's the small Satan. We want to annihilate you, and
all that we're doing is not letting them achieve that. Uh that's
the whole thing. This is a matter of self-defense.
If we had not acted now, later on we could not act, and by then
Iran would have gone nuclear and had thousands of ballistic missiles.
Is your position uh This just factually couldn't be true, right?
There's just no possible way that you
their nuclear capacity completely in midnight hammer, and then
they were on their way to a nuclear weapon where if you didn't
strike immediately,
I think this is just true based on the fact that they went for
Khamenei, right?
They could have not gone for Khamenei, they could have like not
had if they if they just prioritized hitting only military hardware,
right?
Khamenei is like a spiritual leader. He's not even like a like
a true leader at this point, right? He's like a figurehead.
If they'd only attacked the missile facilities, the drone facilities,
all of this stuff, then maybe I'd believe this, but they clearly
wanted to like put a bunch of Iran's politicians and stuff,
Want to get rid of those leaders as
So, like I don't even know
if those weren't your immediate targets, if your priority was
killing Khamenei,
why are you saying any of this? This wasn't the the number one
priority.
in Israel that every country should be properly transparent about
their nuclear
Our position is to not allow nations that explicitly say they
want to annihilate another nation acquire nuclear weapon.
They hate you. They hate America. They say death to America.
Don't you know they say death to
Right, but that countries should be transparent about their nuclear
capability. I think the world needs to prevent from countries
that have genocidal intent acquiring any sort of meaningful weapons,
certainly not nuclear weapons.
I mean, I I think you you're probably ahead of me here. I think
you know why I'm asking you this. It's because Israel has never
admitted whether it has itself got nuclear weapons, and I've
always been quite baffled by this. I've I've asked Benjamin Netanyahu
multiple times, "Has Israel got nuclear weapons?" And he just
doesn't answer. I mean, you're a former prime minister of the
country, so let me ask you, does Israel have nuclear
Israel has always been clear that we're not going to be the first
ones to introduce nuclear weapons to the region, but I want to
be also
okay, like I it's just the dude, it's like they always have a
smirk saying this [__] It's so disrespectful. >> very
clear introduce nuclear country. So, let me ask you, does Israel
have nuclear weapons? Israel has always been clear that we're
not going to be the first ones to introduce nuclear
to the region, but I want to be also very clear. Israel never
has, never had, and never will have any intent on destroying
other countries. It's really simple. If Iran if Hisb Iran it
was the main problem with the Islamic regime was that they were
too honest, okay? They said that they they said that they wanted
to [__] with us. We are a little more covert, okay?
We only say we want the total
and and political pol- political and economic of these countries,
okay? That's all we say. We don't say we want them destroyed.
Like, yeah, we want the Persians like brutally by Kurds and Muslims.
Yes, absolutely. But, that doesn't mean we like want them destroyed.
That's our way of life, isn't
Isn't that a way of life? Bala if Hamas decide to stop wanting
to >> I said Muslims, I meant Arabs. destroy our country,
there will be no wars. We never want any war. All we're doing
is trying to prevent others from destroying us. It's really that
simple.
Right, but but my question is very simple, too. So, does Israel
have nuclear weapons?
I said Israel's policy has always been that we wouldn't be the
first to introduce a nuclear weapon, but I also want to say,
Piers, that creating this sort of uh uh equality or or equating
us to any to Iran or to someone who has
genocidal desires, it's it's false
equivalence. Yeah, but I'm not I'm comparing you I'm comparing
you Well, let me compare you to the United States or the UK or
uh countries like that that have nuclear weapons. They all tell
people, "Yes, we have them, and here's how many we have." The
only country in the world which doesn't answer the question,
although you do seem to be suggesting from your answer that Israel
doesn't have them when most people believe you do. Um and I'm
just curious why it's a question that causes such sort of weird
ambiguity on behalf of Israel. W- Why if everyone else should
be transparent about nuclear capability and is transparent about
it, why does Israel get a pass? Why can't you just say, "Yeah,
we have nuclear weapons." What is the argument here?
What is the argument here? The argument is I think something
along the lines of, "Well, technically,
the devices, the bombs are not attached to a warhead. They're
not Sorry, the the warheads are not attached to missiles yet.
They couldn't be delivered. So, like we don't have nuclear weapons.
We just have like some
We know they stole uranium from America. Um I believe they also
stole technology,
Like, I believe they also stole research. If I'm not If I'm not
incorrect, And here's how many we've got. As I said, we're not
going to be the first ones to introduce, but I I will say that
no other country on Earth
is so And I I believe, Piers, you're you're a very intelligent
guy, and you can ask it in 20 different ways, and I'll All I
can say is there's no other country on Earth that is so threatened
by others. And I also want to say something. We're doing the
work of the >> Oh, I see. It has to do with aid. It is
illegal to give military aid to those who have nukes who haven't
signed a non-proliferation proliferation
treaty. So, if you're not willing to say that you won't build
more nukes, then you can't give build then other uh nuclear non-proliferation
countries cannot give aid to those countries. Oh,
world the hard tough work of neutralizing
genocidal regimes from acquiring nuclear weapons. Look at Iran
right now. They've shot up the Saudis, at Bahrain, at the Emirates,
at the Kuwait, uh at Jordan, even in in at Cyprus in Europe.
They're shooting everyone that didn't even shoot them. So, just
imagine if now they had intercontinental ballistic missiles with
a nuclear warhead. So, instead of thanking Israel for doing this
tough thankless job, everyone's condemning us. So, that's okay.
We're used to being condemned by the world, but I will not apologize
for defending the world and doing everyone else's hard job. We
should be thanked, not condemned.
Uh-huh. What does victory look like to you in this uh war that
has just been started? Thank you, Israel. There were too many
Americans in this world. Thank you,
Well, there's a bunch of options. The most basic one is Iran
totally dismantled from its nuclear program and its ballistic
missile program. However, there is an opportunity and it's not
up to Israel or America to define this. We are creating a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity for the wonderful people of Iran to rise up against
the horrible genocidal regime, this religion
So, overt obvious propaganda being used to try to get as many
people killed by the new crazy leader of the IRGC as they Um
you've heard of atrocity propaganda. These people are fomenting
an atrocity. We're just going to keep convincing these people
that they will have support. It will be okay. You will make
And then, I don't know what's going to happen. just regime that's
been killing and terrorizing its own people. Thank you, Israel.
Thank you. >> And we're creating the conditions for them
to do it. I love that I love that he said you should thank us
repeatedly because now, when we go to the energy crisis segment,
it's going to be awesome and I can just say, "Thank you, Israel."
the whole time. Thank you, Israel. Thank you.
Massive increases in shipping costs all around the world, thank
you, Israel. Massive increases in fuel costs all around the world,
thank you, Israel. Thank you. Thank you,
>> Israel and America were not only targeting nuclear and
ballistic missile targets, we're also targeting the secret police,
those guys
Okay, to be clear, Elamiko,
it's existential for these people. If you had a gun to your head
and you had to remember every line of a script, you might remember
every line of the script pretty quickly, actually.
These people do have a gun to their head basically all the time.
They [__] up a little bit of the script. One time,
this former prime minister of Israel says, "Yeah, we do actually
have nuclear weapons." His country's [__] okay? who
beat up women who don't cover their heads and Basij and IRGC.
And we're hitting them more and more and weakening the regime.
So, if you will, the chains of oppression that are on the Iranian
people are becoming weaker and weaker, but they'll have to sort
of remove those chains and rise up. This is something we cannot
guarantee. It's up to them to decide. Just every line. Dude,
I can't believe Trump just openly took the script, too. That's
what's most embarrassing to me or would be embarrassing to me,
I guess, if he was my elected representative.
Right? That like they all hit every line on the script, but then
Trump hits every line on the script, too. Which is just very
funny. It's very
Yeah, it's crazy, man.
That's all he's been at. Thank you for coming back on censored.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, Piers.